[MUSIC PLAYING]
PATRICK CLAY: Hello, everyone
My name is Patrick Clay.
And I'm an engineer working
on Google Cloud Dataproc.
I'm here today to
demonstrate to you
how you can use Apache Spark
MLlib on Google Cloud Dataproc
to gain insight in your
data, to train models,
and then to deploy
those into production.
I know that you've heard a
lot about machine learning
on the Google Cloud Platform
over the past couple of days,
but I hope by the end of
this you will walk away
thinking that Spark MLlib
is a tool that you should
be excited about and consider
trying, if you haven't already.
My talk will primarily be a demo
of Spark MLlib on Google Cloud
Dataproc.
But before that, I wanted
to introduce the tools
that I'll be using the demo,
not just MLlib and Dataproc,
but BigQuery and Cloud Datalab.
And at the end I'll try to wrap
things up and make comparisons
to our new suite of
machine learning offerings.
So before I dive
into this, just so I
can have a sense
of the audience,
can I see a show of hands who
has used the tools that I just
mentioned?
I'll mention them again.
Who's used BigQuery?
OK, quite a few hands.
Cloud Datalab?
Couple.
Dataproc?
Oh, good, getting a couple.
And Apache Spark, either
on Dataproc or elsewhere?
OK, that's a lot.
Guess that's why you're here.
So doesn't need too much
of an introduction based
on your hands, but BigQuery is
the oldest and possibly most
popular data processing
tool on our Cloud.
It's our one-stop data
warehouse nSQL engine.
And it's best use case
is scaling your queries
for megabytes to terabytes,
even to petabytes if you need,
without ever worrying about
configuring resources,
setting indexes, just
scales as you need.
So I like to think of
as interactive speed,
that when you're in
the BigQuery console,
you can just write a query, and
before you have to switch tabs,
certainly before you have
to walk down the hall to get
a coffee, your query runs.
However, the world
isn't all SQL.
And sometimes you want to do
things like machine learning.
So that's where Cloud
Datalab comes in.
Datalab adds a bunch of rich
features to Google Cloud
Storage services, like BigQuery.
So it can take data from
Cloud SQL, Cloud Storage,
or BigQuery, and then
process that data inside
of a Jupyter-based
cloud notebook with all
of your favorite Python
data processing libraries,
pandas, NumPy, ScPy.
It can also process them
on Cloud distributed
processing engines, like
Dataflow, Dataproc, or now,
ML Engine.
If you want to do
machine learning inside
of Cloud Datalab as TensorFlow
and scikit-learn and
has really nice visualizations.
OK so we're here to
talk about, or I'm here
to talk about
Apache Spark, which
I think combines a lot of
the best aspects of BigQuery
and Datalab.
You might think of Apache Spark
as just a general distributed
processing engine on the
JVM, like Hadoop MapReduce
but maybe a little more memory
optimized, maybe a little more
higher level, like Apache Beam.
And that's all true.
But really in the
last two years,
Spark has tried to
differentiate itself
by adding layers on top of
its base processing engine,
the first being Spark SQL.
And I really like
Spark SQL because I
like processing in SQL.
I like data frames.
In Python, I like using the
pandas library, or NumPy.
So when I'm using
Spark, I almost entirely
use some form of Spark SQL.
MLlib, the machine learning
library I'm here to talk about,
is now currently almost
entirely based on Spark SQL.
So if you can write SQL,
if you can use data frames,
you can use MLlib.
MLlib, I guess that is
machine learning library,
it's API was inspired
scikit-learn.
And it is many, many
machine learning algorithms.
It is kind of all of your
classics, linear and logistic
regression, k means clustering,
it has kind of your workhorse
algorithms, like random forest,
or simple vector machines,
and even some esoteric
algorithms like [? latent ?]
Dirichlet allocation.
But there's more
to machine learning
than running algorithms.
You have to convert your data
from whatever form you find it
into standardized features.
And this is another
place where MLlib shines,
because it's based on Spark.
And Spark is,
first and foremost,
a data processing engine.
So it's really simple
to take raw text data,
convert it into
initially numerical data,
and then vectorized data,
all those transformations
are built in and
very easy to use.
Once you have your
transformations
and your algorithms,
you compress them
together into pipelines,
which you run a train models.
And then you can
improve the models
with hyper-parameter tuning.
And I will show you all
of that in the demo.
Unfortunately, Spark can
be a little painful to use.
It requires, at the
very least, a cluster
of machines, which Google
Compute Engine can provide,
but then you have to
install the software,
configure it, all
of these things.
So that's where Google
Cloud Dataproc comes in.
This is the product I work on.
And it provides a fully managed
cluster running Apache Spark,
Apache Hadoop, Pig, and Hive.
And on top of these, it adds
the Cloud Storage file system,
so that you can keep
all of your data in GCS.
You don't have to worry about
maintaining your cluster,
and BigQuery connector
for structured data.
One of kind of the lesser known
features of Cloud Dataproc
is being able to mix in
many different things,
but certainly cloud notebooks.
So I've already
mentioned Datalab,
but there's also Apache
Zeppelin, which came out
of the Spark community, and
Jupyter, the original notebook,
as it were, which work really
well with Spark because Spark
is so memory optimized,
that just like BigQuery,
if you're sitting in that
interactive cloud notebook
environment, you just run
a couple of lines of code
and see your results
within seconds.
Dataproc is really fast.
You can give it, if you
want a 10 node cluster,
you can have it in
under two minutes.
If you decide 10 nodes,
10 VMs is enough,
you can have 100 VMs
in another two minutes.
The configuration, it's
really easy to use.
You say, I'd like a cluster.
If you want to do more
configuration, you can do that.
And lastly and most
importantly, it's ephemeral.
So all of your data stays
in a cloud storage service.
And you don't have
to worry about it.
So how does this
all fit together?
So, that's quite pale.
But the Datalab runs inside
of a Docker container
on a Compute Engine VM inside
of the Dataproc cluster.
Datalab uses Spark's
Python, PySpark APIs,
to access Spark across all
the nodes of the cluster.
And both Spark and Datalab
access Google Cloud Services,
such as Cloud
Storage and BigQuery.
The user accesses Datalab
just as they normally
would when running on GCE.
So without further ado, let's
switch to the demo, show this.
Cool.
So this, as most of you raised
your hands should recognize,
is BigQuery.
And today I will be looking
at the New York City
Taxi and Limousine Commission
Yellow Taxi Cab data sets.
It's one of my favorite public
data sets on Google Cloud.
We have quite a few,
mostly on BigQuery,
which you can see here, some
in Google Cloud Storage,
and now some on PubSub.
If you saw the
keynote yesterday,
you saw a demo of using
BigQuery Dataflow and ML
Engine to analyze
people who were
coming from airports and near
food, for advertising purposes.
It's quite slick.
Today I'm not interested in
such a specific question.
I have a broad question.
Where are people in New
York catching taxicabs?
Specifically at a given time
on a given day of a week,
where in New York are
taxicab pickups happening?
So I don't need this
entire data set, which
is why I will run this
query to filter out,
to only select the pickups.
And it's important that
I filter this data,
because if you, one nice
thing in BigQuery is you
can preview your data.
And you'll notice that there's
a lot of problematic entries,
in any data set, but
certainly a free data
set, as all these zeros.
And I want to train my
model on taxi cab pick ups
off the coast of West Africa.
So clean my model and put
it in this taxicab data
set, which you'll see,
still has a billion records
even after that filtering.
And we need some
way to process this.
So I will use my terminal to
spin up a Dataproc cluster.
Normally I would use the
Cloud console to spin it up.
And mostly, but not all of
these legs are available.
This is a 20 node
cluster, because why not.
I can scale out.
This initialization
action, which
is like a dual compute
startup scripts,
except you can specify
more than one of them.
And this particular
one installs Datalab.
You can specify both of those
inside of the Cloud console,
but I had a JavaScript issue
with one of my libraries.
So I am using a--
I'm telling the
initialization action
to use a different docker image
than normal, but essentially
just regularly running
the initialization action.
So Datalab, when running on GCE,
opens a web server, or web UI,
inside of a cluster.
And I need to be able to access
that from outside the cluster.
So our suggested way of doing
that is to SSH into the cluster
and create an SSH tunnel.
You could also open
ports in your firewall,
but that's considered
less secure.
And so I do this instead.
And now, in yet
another terminal,
I have too many terminals.
I can open a special
Google Chrome
that is configured
to use this proxy.
And where is that?
Oh that's on my other screen.
And I bring that over.
And if I can still
find my first terminal,
we're still deploying
the cluster.
So it takes two minutes, takes
a little more than two minutes
if you're running
initialization actions.
There you go.
So now, hopefully, I go
to welcome to Datalab.
Very important note,
Datalab is no longer beta.
This doesn't apply anymore.
Datalab went GA this week,
or generally available.
But like I said, I was
using an old docker image.
You can load notebooks in
a Datalab a number of ways,
but I'm just going to
load one from my machine.
So if I upload my Python
notebook and double
click on it, hopefully.
OK, this is a Datalab notebook.
If you're at all familiar with
Jupyter, or Zeppelin, or even
Matlab or Mathematica, you'll
be familiar with these cell
kind of notebook things.
The first thing I'm going to
do, kind of as a preamble,
is to install a Google
Maps visualization
library that I'll use later.
But I wanted to do that and
get that out of the way.
And that's not a good sign.
Oh, there you go, all good.
And just reloads, loads the
JavaScript, OK, onto the rest.
So the first thing
you have to do
when data processing
in Spark is load data.
And it's not glamorous.
So I'm just going to try to get
it all out of the way at once.
You can see that Datalab has
provided very convenient Google
Cloud Storage and APIs
that allow me to extract
the table that I just created
in BigQuery as compressed
CSV in Google Cloud Storage.
And when that finishes we will
be able to load it into Spark.
And because we are using
Spark's SQL and data frames,
we can just infer the
schema from that CSV record,
except that there is
a bug, and the dates
don't get parsed correctly.
So I have to do manual
date processing.
Oh, there we go.
So I've printed out the
schema of my data frame.
And you can see that the
date column written here
is a string.
So I'm converting it
to a date in Spark,
not at all interesting
and not related to MLlib.
Now I'm just previewing my data.
One great thing about Spark
is that you don't actually
have to load all of your
data at all to preview it.
So you can just look
at a tiny piece.
So that's what we've done here.
I should of actually ask
before, is this legible back?
OK, good.
And so you see now
we have a nice,
when the taxi was picked
up, where it was picked up,
somewhere in New
York in the Lat long.
In Datalab we can run
queries against BigQuery.
Also in Spark, you
can register SQL,
you can register SQL tables.
So I'm just running
a simple select count
star against both
BigQuery and Spark
to make sure that I
have all the data.
It takes a long time in Spark
because this data is still
sitting in GCS.
Spark is lazy.
So until I say
select count start,
it will actually
never load the data.
Once that finishes,
what I want to do
is I need to bucket my data into
the hour and day of the week,
so I can ask the question,
on a typical Thursday
morning at 10:00 AM, how
many taxicabs were there
in New York City?
And so this SQL query
just buckets my data
by hour, day of week, and
city block, essentially,
one thousandth of a GPS
coordinate, or of a degree
of latitude or longitude.
So you can see we
haven't lost any data.
We have all the records.
And we can start
machine learning.
That needs to run.
And, oh, that's all right.
While that's running, I'd like
to introduce the Spark MLlib
API.
MLlib's API, actually my
favorite thing about it,
beyond its convenience
and its use,
because I think
it's really slick.
There are four main classes
in MLlib, transformers, which
take data and output new data.
Really what they do is
they all add a column
to your data frame.
So they just add a column
to your SQL data structure.
There are estimators
which take your data frame
and output a trained model.
So these are all the
algorithms I mentioned,
the regressors, the
classifiers, the clusters.
Then there's the model
itself, which takes your data
and makes predictions
based on it.
And the really neat thing
is predictions are just
another column of data.
And I said transformers are
things that take your data
and add a column.
So models are
transformers, which
means you can
compose them in just
a sequence of transformers,
and then an estimator,
you fit it to get a model.
And you keep transforming.
The way that you compose
them, the best way,
is inside a pipeline.
And here is a picture
from, this is just
from the Spark documentation.
You can find it, just
Spark ML pipelines.
But setting taxis
aside for a second,
suppose you had some
raw text, like say,
the works of Shakespeare.
And you wanted to classify
them into, say, categories,
comedies, tragedies, etc.
One way you could go about
this is you take your raw text,
you'd split it into
words, or possibly n-grams
depending on your model.
Then you need to somehow
convert these words
into some kind of
numeric feature vector.
And then finally you train
an estimator on that.
So in this case, Spark
provides just plug and play,
a tokenizer, many different
things, but a hashing
transform, and a logistic
regression estimator.
You put all of these
together in a pipeline.
And then you fit the pipeline.
And you end up with your
trained model that you
can transform into predictions.
So this is again straight out of
the Spark's API documentation.
The high level is
we create toy code,
but it has this text column.
We define these
transforms and estimators,
all in like one line of
code and throw them together
into a pipeline,
fit it to our data.
We get a model.
You run the model, or
you create toy test data.
And then you transform the
model to get predictions.
So really this is,
in this case, it's
a very glorified word count.
The data is designed
so that Spark
is, if the data contains
the word Spark, it's 1,
otherwise it's 0.
But in general, you could do
more fancy transformations,
like topic determination
in the Shakespeare example.
So if I scroll back
up, the last thing I
said when I
preprocessed data was
that I'd like to describe it.
I know this top
column is quite faint.
But here's the final
state of our data.
There's the hour
in which, the hour
in the day, between 0 and
23, when she was picked up,
the day of the week,
1 being Monday,
7 being Sunday, and our latitude
and longitude bucketized,
so rounded to the thousandth,
the count of the number
of pickups in this region.
And then just because it's
kind of unreasonable to train
a model from one to 5,000,
I took the log of that
so it's between 0 and 11,
which is more manageable.
So now let's actually do
some machine learning.
So this should look very similar
to the text processing example,
except we don't need to do
much transformation because I
chose to use a random
forest regressor.
And one of the wonderful
things about random forest
is they don't require
much pre-processing.
They can take numeric data.
They don't need
normalize, or categorical,
or fancy transformations, which
Spark and MLlib can all do.
But so, all I do is take the
columns that I'm interested in,
I put them in a vector
called features.
I tell the regressor,
look at the features
and try to predict the
label column, which
is that log space feature
column, and run predictions.
And if I run that now
we get some predictions.
So some of these
are pretty good.
There's only one pick up here.
It predicted a very low amount.
This is a pretty
perfect, one for one.
But some of them are pretty
not so great, like this one.
So let's be more specific.
I didn't mention evaluators
in my ML classes,
but they're also very important.
So you can take the
evaluator and find
that our R squared
values about one half,
and our root-mean-squared
error is about 1 and 1/2.
So in layman's terms, I mean
the root-mean-squared error
means that in logarithmic space
we're off by usually about 50%.
So if there were
six passengers, we
might think there is between
4 and 9, which isn't too bad.
Or sorry, not six passengers,
six taxis leaving in that hour.
But I still don't have a
great sense of how good or bad
our model is.
So what I'm going to do
is rely on Cloud Datalab's
visualization
capabilities and sample
both the real data
and simulated data,
where the simulated data
takes the number of pickups
that we predicted and
randomly generates them
inside that bucket.
So this is the
Google Maps library
that I loaded at the beginning.
And it forms a very nice
Google Maps heat map.
So this is what we predict
during rush hour at Thursday.
We seem to have found
Manhattan, which is good.
But we have a lot of pickups
in the middle of East River.
And it's generally
kind of messy.
If you compare this
to the real data,
you'll see this is a very nice
and pretty, because that's
what the real data is.
It's all in the streets.
LaGuardia is all nice.
So clearly we have
some work to do.
We can also look at the
middle of the night,
again on a Thursday.
And it really is no better,
whereas reality is, again,
quite nice and clean.
Also in real life, less
people are catching taxis
in the middle of the
night on a Thursday,
but we didn't really learn that.
So how do we improve our model?
So every estimator, but
also pretty much every class
in MLlib, has this
extractParamMap method,
where you can look at the
parameters inside of it.
So this is what our random
forest regressor ran
with in the default parameters.
I'll draw your attention to,
the trees are only of depth 5.
Trees are only of depth 5,
and there were 20 of them.
Not much of a forest, and
not much in terms of trees.
So we could go
and rerun the code
with a deeper tree,
or more trees.
But then we have to
worry about overtraining
and all of these things.
So really the trick is to
let Spark do the work for you
and set up a parameter
grid, and say,
please consider trees
of depth 5 and 15,
and set the number of
trees to both 5 and 20.
Build this whole grid
and then evaluate.
There are a couple different
ways to run all of your grid.
I used a trainValidationSplit.
You could also use
cross-validation.
It's not a big deal.
This is one case
where Spark does
take a long time, which
is why I kicked off all
my data processing beforehand.
Cross-validation takes a long
time because as a general rule,
Spark will never transform
the same data twice
at the same time.
And so unfortunately when
you run your parameter grid,
it will only ever use one
piece of the grid at a time.
And if you've scaled out as
I have, it's pretty fast.
But it's still not great.
So with this, I
took the best model
and evaluated it on
my validation data.
And we got a better R
squared, 0.73, not the best
but our root-mean-squared error
is now getting more reasonable.
And if we go back and
look at our models,
we can re-simulate the data.
And now this kind of
looks respectable.
We don't have pickups in the
middle of the East River.
Usually we have
pickups at LaGuardia.
OK, that was bad, should
have fixed the seed.
Anyways, but we found
Manhattan much better.
And it looks much more like the
real data, same with midnight.
We still think that there are
more pickups than there are,
but at least they're at
reasonable locations.
And for the sake of time, I
didn't set a huge parameter
grid or super deep trees.
But if you train on all the data
with super deep trees, or trees
of depth 30, which is
as deep as Spark goes,
you can get up above 90%, or an
R squared value of over 0.95.
I kind of glossed over splitting
the data into test validation
and training, but I did.
And here's the
actual test results.
And they're exactly in line with
our validation, which is good.
We didn't overfit our model.
And pretty much
everything I've done here
could be done on
any Spark cluster
on GCE, assuming you had one.
But the last great
thing about MLlib
is the ability to take
models and reuse them later.
So if you've seen talks on
ML Engine and version models,
and certain models in the
Cloud, this isn't exactly that,
but it's somewhat
similar in that we
can take the model
that we just trained,
I don't even know what this
model is, it's the best
model that that grid put
out, and write it out to GCS,
and take any data, but in
this case, our test data,
write that also out
to Cloud Storage.
And then after tearing down
our cluster in another cluster
a year from now, we can just
load the model, load our data,
run our predictions, write
them out, write them out again,
evaluate them, do
whatever we like.
And at least these four are
completely agnostic as to what
we did in our data processing.
All I know is that I made
a Spark MLlib pipeline.
But these four lines of
code are absolutely reusable
over and over again.
And to demonstrate that,
if I go back to one of my,
go back to one of my
terminals, actually
if I go back to my
other Chrome browser,
I have this file in
GCS called predict.pi.
And it just does
those four lines.
Load the model, loads
some data, transform
the data using the model
to make predictions,
save that out to
Cloud Storage again.
I can submit this as a job to
Cloud Dataproc using the jobs
API.
And the jobs API,
if your view Spark,
this is essentially the
same as running Spark a bit
on a Python application.
There's too much log spam
that I should filter out.
Actually, I was running
that on the same cluster.
I meant to run that
on a different cluster
to demonstrate that I don't
need to know about anything
that went on in that cluster.
This is an entirely
separate cluster.
You can't really
see that, but it is.
And there we are.
And now it will take
that data, transform it,
write those predictions out.
And you can use those
predictions somewhere else.
So if you were using Cloud
Datalab or any notebook,
generate a model in
an interactive, kind
of ad hoc exploratory way,
you can save that model,
send it off to another engineer,
another team, doesn't matter,
use that model over
and over again.
And that is really
a lot of log spam.
But it says right
there, finished
with predictions, which was
the all done, successful job.
And that's all I
have in the demo.
So if we could go
back to the slides.
To wrap things up,
hopefully you just
saw how Spark and
Dataproc can leverage
Spark SQL to do very useful,
kind of ad hoc data processing,
MLlib to take that data
processing and add very simple,
three line machine learning
APIs on top of that.
When you use it
with Datalab, you
get that interactive,
just run, go back and edit
your parameters options.
Or you can use parameter
grid so you don't have to.
And that beautiful visualization
of Google Maps, Google Charts,
and other things.
And lastly with the
Dataproc jobs API,
you can take all of
your trained models
and reuse them elsewhere.
So I promised I'd talk
about other machine learning
offerings, compare
and contrast them.
So what about Cloud ML Engine?
It's similar to MLlib
in many respects.
You train your models in
a distributed fashion.
You can persist the
models for later use.
And the high level
API of TensorFlow,
if you to the talks, one
of the high level APIs,
it's called tf.learn.
Both tf.learn and MLlib are
both based on scikit-learn.
So a lot of the
estimator model, that
should also feel pretty
similar between the two.
There are some
differences, but it
should be pretty much the same.
However, they do each
have key strengths.
ML Engine was written
for TensorFlow,
or it is TensorFlow.
So TensorFlow was written first
and foremost for deep learning.
So if you want deep
learning, I highly
recommend TensorFlow
on ML Engine.
Spark does have deep learning.
They do over neural nets.
But it's been, or MLlib
does, but it's not
its intended
first-class purpose.
ML Engine is server-less, sure
you've heard that word a lot
recently.
Dataproc is not.
Dataproc, you don't have
to maintain a server,
you can spin one up, take one
down, but you do have GC EVMs.
And there's advantages
to both ways.
One of the advantage
of being server-less is
a user with a cell phone,
or a client on a cell phone,
can make a call to
the Prediction API.
You don't have to worry about
managing infrastructure at all.
The advantage of
having the cluster
around is you can have your
data cache in memory in Spark.
And you can do
that kind of ad hoc
iterative exploratory analysis.
Furthermore you can do
the kind of general Spark
processing, or
pre-processing, on your data.
So all that kind of painful SQL
munging I did at the beginning,
you could do in Dataflow,
or Spark, and Beam,
and then run on ML Engine, but
it's all sitting there for you
with Spark on Dataproc.
And the last key
advantage, or, I
didn't mention the interactive
speed with the cache memory.
The last key advantage of
MLlib is that all of the APIs
have 10 parameters.
You don't need to specify them.
They work out of the box.
You can auto tune them.
And they can be written in
like the four lines of code
that I showed at the very end.
The last similarity
that I didn't
mention when I was
mentioning the similarities,
is that both are
built on open source.
So the keynote today,
there was a lot
of talk about how TensorFlow
is, in many respects, one
of the hottest,
open source projects
out there right now,
certainly if you
look at GitHub statistics.
When I checked,
Spark and TensorFlow
are the two most
forked GitHub projects.
So they're both very
similar in that respect.
And they're both still getting
incredible amount of commits,
TensorFlow just went 1.0.
Spark went 2.0 last
summer, but is continuing
to iterate and evolve.
So it's kind of really
an exciting time
to be using either tool.
And with [INAUDIBLE]
and Dataproc,
you constantly leverage all of
the improvements that are being
driven in both communities.
So that's essentially
all I have.
If I've encourage you to
go try any of this out,
I have some helpful links.
My demo is not available on any
of these links, but it will be.
At some point these slides
will be available, I believe.
And the demo should be linkable
through one of the quick starts
there at the Cloud
Dataproc Quick Starts.
We also have tutorials,
the initialization actions,
including the
Datalab one I demoed.
There's resources on Spark
ML and Cloud Datalab.
And lastly for the New
York City Taxi data set,
you can go and look
up our version of it.
But if you just Google New
York City Taxi data set,
you can find lots of great
and interesting other data
science projects that people
have leveraged it for.
And that might inspire you.
These links are also
possibly helpful
if you get stuck on any
of the quick starts.
They're mostly Dataproc specific
because they route to me.
The Stack Overflow also
has the Apache Spark MLlib.
[MUSIC PLAYING]